David Clinton has written and created many
popular technical books and video courses.
This data analytics course, along with the
accompanying website, and Jupyter Notebooks
will help you learn data analytics in 30 days.
Welcome to my course, I'm really glad to have
you here. And I'm even happier that you've
decided to join the data analytics party.
Who am I, I'm the author of more than a dozen
books on Linux and AWS administration, digital
security, and dozens of courses on Pluralsight.
I've also got a fistful of articles right
here on the Free Code Camp news site. But
I just write about stuff. Hopefully, when
you're done with this content, you'll be out
using data to change the world. Since you've
already seen my claim that this will only
take you 30 days, I should explain what this
actually is going to show you the tools you'll
need to find and manipulate raw data, and
use various graphing tools to help you understand
and interpret it. But don't expect us to cover
a full data science curriculum here complete
with single and multivariable calculus, algorithmic
problem solving, or even machine learning.
That would require a whole lot more time and
effort. If that's what you're after, check
out the new data science content that Free
Code Camp is in the process of bringing online,
there's something else you won't get from
these videos experience. Once you've watched
the entire course, you probably still won't
be able to do much on your own. The value
of actual hands on experience is the mistakes
you make, you know, Miss typing syntax, not
properly understanding what your code is doing,
or failing to account for Environment specific
restrictions. diagnosing and working through
those mistakes is where you'll really begin
to take charge and accomplish great things.
So where will you get that experience? If
you're ambitious, and you've got exciting
project ideas of your own, by all means, dive
in and try it out. But if you think you still
need some guidance, then I've got everything
you should need on my stories dot the data
project dotnet site, you can work through
the exercises in each of eight data stories
that you'll find over there. If there's a
specific skill you're looking for the learning
objectives index down here will point you
directly to the chapter where you'll find
it all that's available for anyone and for
free. If you happen to prefer working with
a real book, you can purchase the same content
in that format. But don't think anything's
missing from the free website.
But right now,
let's talk about data analytics tools. There
are many ways to consume data, the one you
choose will reflect your specific needs, and
your comfort with various skills. spreadsheets,
as you probably already know, are much more
than just fancy calculators or places to keep
your household budget numbers. They also come
with powerful functions, external integrations
and graphing capabilities. Enterprise strength
tools like Tableau Splunk, or Microsoft's
Power BI, are also great for crunching numbers
and visualizing insights, which you can then
share with your team members. So then what's
the big deal with Python? Well, the Python
ecosystem is much, much broader than those
purpose build tools. And the Python community
makes all kinds of useful data specific libraries
and modules available. When you let Python
loose against your data. You've got all the
resources of a full bore industrial strength
programming language at your fingertips. It's
not what you can do with it. That's the challenge.
It's finding something that you can't do.
OK, but what about Jupiter? Jupiter is an
open source platform within which you can
load your data and execute your Python code.
It's a lot like a programming Id like Microsoft
Visual Studio. And while Jupyter Notebooks
can be used with a growing number of languages,
and for as many tasks as you can imagine,
it's best known and loved as a host for Python
data heroics. Once upon a time, the lines
of code you'd write for your programs would
be saved to a single text file whose name
ended with a dot p y suffix. When you want
it to run your code to see how things went.
You do it from the command line or a powerful
and complicated source code editor like Visual
Studio. But for anything to work, it all had
to work. That would make it harder to troubleshoot
when something didn't go according to spec.
But it would also make it a lot harder to
play around with specific details just to
see what happens. And it also made it tough
to share live versions of your code across
the internet. As we'll soon see, Jupyter Notebooks
let you run your code a single line at a time,
or altogether. That flexibility makes it easier
to understand your code and when things go
wrong to troubleshoot it. notebooks, by the
way, are JSON based files that effectively
move the processing environment for just about
any data oriented programming code from your
server or workstation to your web browser.
You can download Jupiter to your PC or a private
server and access the interface through any
browser with network access. Or you can run
notebooks on third party hosting services
like Google's core laboratory, or for a cost
cloud providers like Amazon's Sage maker studio
notebooks, or Microsoft's as your notebook.
Jupiter comes in three flavors. The two you're
most likely to encounter are classic notebooks
and the newer Jupiter lab. Both run nicely
within your browser. But Jupiter lab comes
with more extensions and lets you work with
multiple notebook files and terminal access
within a single browser tab. I'll be using
the classic notebook environment for the demos
in this course, but there's usually no problem
transferring notebooks between versions. The
third labor just to be complete is Jupiter
hub. A server version built to provide authenticated
notebook access to multiple users, you can
serve up to 100 or so users from a single
cloud server using the littlest Jupiter hub.
For larger deployments involving clusters
of servers, it probably be better off with
a Kubernetes version known as zero to Jupiter
hub with Kubernetes. But all that's way beyond
the scope of this course. Our next job is
to build our work environment. Assuming you've
decided to host Jupiter on your own machine,
you'll need Python installed. The good news
is that most operating systems come with Python
pre installed, you can confirm that you've
got an up to date version of Python by opening
a command prompt and typing Python dash dash
version or sometimes Python three dash dash
version, a pythons installed, you'll probably
see something like this. Just make sure you've
got Python three installed and not the deprecated
and insecure Python two. If you do need to
install Python manually, you're best off using
pythons official documentation that will be
the most complete and up to date source available
that will work with whatever operating system
you're on. It's important to note that not
all Python versions even those from three
point x will necessarily behave quite the
way you expect. You may for instance, find
that you need a library written for version
3.9. But that there's no way to get it working
on your 3.7 system.
Upgrading your system version to 3.9 might
work out well for you. But it could also cause
some unexpected and unpleasant consequences.
It's hard to know when a particular Python
library might also be needed by your core
operating system. If you pull the original
version of the library, he might end up disabling
the OS itself. And don't think it won't happen.
I crippled my own O's that way just a few
months ago. One solution is to run Python
for your project within a special virtual
environment that's isolated from your larger
o 's. That way, you can install all the libraries
and versions you like without having to worry
about damaging your work system. You can do
this using a full scale virtual container
running a Docker or as I prefer LX D image
or on a standalone AWS cloud instance. But
you can also use pythons own v n module, you
want to read the official documentation for
the virtual environment instructions specific
to your host OS. Whichever version of Jupiter
you choose, if you decide to install and run
it locally, the Jupiter project officially
recommends doing it through the Python Anaconda
distribution and its binary package manager
conda. Various guides to doing that are available
for various OS hosts, but this official page
is a good place to start. As you can see though,
the Python PIP package manager is also an
option. Once all that's done, you should be
able to open a notebook right in your browser
and get right down to work. For me, a notebooks
most powerful feature is the way you can run
subsets of your code within individual cells.
This makes it easier to break down long and
complex programs into easily readable and
executable snippets. With a cell selected.
Clicking the Run button will execute just
that cells code. Note how the box on the left
gets a number representing the sequential
position of the execution. As you become more
familiar with Jupiter, you'll probably get
in the habit of executing cells using Ctrl
and enter rather than a mouse click, you can
insert a new cell right after the one that's
currently selected by clicking the plus button.
the up and down arrows move cells as you might
expect, up and down. cells, by default are
formatted to handle code, Python three in
my case, but they can also be set for markdown
which can be handy for documenting your notebooks,
or making new sections easier to find. A single
hashtag in markdown, for instance, represents
a top level selection title, executing the
cell will print the text to match your formatting
instruction. The precise locations and appearance
of the buttons you'll use to get this stuff
done will vary between the different Jupiter
versions, but all the basic functions are
universally available. Whatever values your
code creates, will remain in the kernel memory
until the output from a particular cell or
for the entire kernel are cleared. This lets
you rerun previous or subsequent cells to
see what impact the change might have. It
also means resetting your environment for
a complete start over is as easy as selecting
restart kernel and clear all outputs.
Not all Python functionality will be available
out of the box. Sometimes, as you saw just
before, you'll need to tell Python to load
one or more modules through declarations within
your code. But some modules need to be installed
manually from the host command line before
they can even be imported. For such cases,
Python recommends their installer program
Pip, or in some cases, the conda tool from
the Anaconda distribution. You can read more
about using PIP for the proper care and feeding
of your Python system within the helpful Python
documentation site. Okay, here's where we
get down to real work. We're going to head
out to the internet to find reliable data
that will help us answer a real world question.
And we'll use a public API to get the data.
Then we'll examine the data to get a feel
for its current formatting, and what it'll
take to fix it. After applying the necessary
formatting, so our code can happily read it
will merge multiple data sets together so
we can look for correlations, and then experiment
with graphing tools to find the one that represents
our data in the most intelligible way. What's
the problem we're trying to solve? I'm curious
to see whether wages paid to us workers over
the past 20 years have on average, gone up,
assuming they have increased, I'd also like
to know whether the extra money in their pockets
has also increased their actual standard of
living? To answer those questions, we're going
to access two data sets collected and maintained
by the US government's Bureau of Labor Statistics.
One of the many nice things about the Bureau
of Labor Statistics usually referred to as
BLS, is that they provide an API for access
from within our Python scripts. To make that
work, you'll need to know the BLS endpoint
address matching the specific data series
you need the Python code to initiate the request,
and for higher volume requests a BLS API key.
Getting the series endpoint addresses you
need may take some digging around in the BLS
website. However, the most popular data sets
are accessible through a single page. This
shows you what that looks like, including
the endpoint codes like lns, one one and a
whole lot of zeros for the civilian labor
force said, You can also search for data sets
on this page. Searching for a computer for
instance, will take you to a list that includes
the deeply tempting average hourly wage for
level 11 computer and mathematical occupations
in Austin, Round Rock, Texas. The information
you'll discover by expanding that selection
will include its series ID, which is the end
point because I know you can barely contain
your curiosity. I'll click through and show
you that it turns out that level 11 computer
in mathematical professions in Austin, Round
Rock Texas, could expect to earn $51.76 an
hour back in 2019. So how do you turn those
series IDs into Python friendly data? manually
writing get and put requests can be very picky,
and it'll take a lot of tries before you get
it exactly right. To avoid all that, I decided
to go with a third party Python library called
BLS. that's available through all of our share
roses GitHub repo, you install the library
on your host machine, using pip install BLS.
That's all it'll take.
While we're here, we might as well activate
our BLS API key. You register for the API
From this page, and they'll send you an email
with your key and a validation URL that you'll
need to click. Once you've got your key, you
export it to your system environment on Linux,
or Mac OS, that would mean running something
like this, where your key is substituted for
the fake one I'm using here, I'm going to
use the API to request us consumer price index,
CPI, and wage and salary statistics between
2002 and 2020. The CPI is a measure of the
price of a basket of essential consumer goods.
It's an important proxy for changes in the
cost of living, which in turn, is an indicator
of the general health of the economy. Our
wages data will come from the BLS employment
cost index, covering wages and salaries for
private industry workers in all industries
and occupations. A growing employment index
would at first glance, suggests that things
are getting better for most people. However,
seeing the average employment wage trends
in isolation isn't all that useful. After
all, the highest salary won't do you much
good if your basic expenses are higher still.
So the goal is to pull both the CPI and wages
data sets, and then correlate them looking
for patterns. This will show us how wages
have been changing in relation to costs. Now,
let me show you how it actually works. With
valid endpoints for the two data sets we are
going to be using, we're all set to start
digging for CPI, and employment gold. Importing
these four libraries, including BLS will give
us all the tools we'll need. pandas stands
for Python for data analysis, which is a library
for working with data as data frames. Data
frames are perhaps the most important structure
you'll use as you learn to process large data
sets. NumPy is a library for executing mathematical
functions against large arrays of data. And
map plot live is a library for plotting data
in visual graphs of various kinds. when importing
a library, you assign it the name you'll use
to invoke it. You can choose just about anything
but pandas is often represented by PD NumPy
as NP and matplotlib as PLT, I'm also importing
the BLS library that we installed a bit earlier,
that will be invoked using its actual name,
BLS. I'll execute that cell. Now I pass the
BLS endpoint for the CPI data series to the
BLS get series command from the BLS library.
The endpoint code itself was of course, copied
from the popular data sets page on the BLS
website, I'll assign the data series that
comes back to a data frame using the variable
CPI, and then save the data frame to a local
CSV file. This isn't necessary, but you might
find it easier to work with the data when
it's saved locally. Next, I'll load the data
from the new CSV file using the pan das PD
read CSV command against the file name. I'll
assign the variable name CPI data to the new
data frame that comes out the other end. Running
just CPI data will print out the first and
last five lines of the data frame. The date
column contains month and year values. And
the second column contains our actual data.
I'd like to simplify the headers to make them
easier to work with. So I'll use the pan das
columns attribute I definitely prefer this
way. However, we'll need to also see the wages
data to know whether the formatted uses is
compatible with our CPI set. So I'll pull
the wages data series using the BLS library
and assign it to the wages data frame. Once
again, I'll save it to a local CSV file and
read that data into a new data frame called
df. I'll clean up my column headers and use
head to print only the first five lines of
data, you should notice two things. This data
isn't delivered in monthly increments, but
quarterly, but only one entry for every three
months. And the date format is different.
Instead of a month number, there's q1 or q2.
If you want Python to sync between our two
data sets, we'll need to do some editing.
I'll do that by replacing every March data
point meaning any date entry containing the
string dash 03 within its date value with
the string q one June that is a string including
dash 06 we'll get q2 and so on. As you can
see now when I print just the date column,
some values have been updated to the new format.
But the rest of them are from this point unnecessary
and will cause us trouble So we'll have to
get rid of them altogether. I'll do that by
creating a new data frame called New CPI and
reading into it the contents of the old CPI
data data frame. But I'll use the pan das
string dot contains function to identify all
the rows in the data frame that contain a
dash. And by specifying false, dropping them,
we'll be left with only properly formatted
quarterly data points. And I said, I'll save
this data frame to a CSV file to notice how
we've dropped from 232 rows to just 77. Just
because I'm paranoid, I'll create a new data
frame called New df. So the old df data frame
will still be available to me, should I accidentally
make a mess with what we're about to do next,
with our data all neatened up, we're ready
to begin our analysis. We've got a big problem
here, the data in the CPI set comes in absolute
point values. While the wages are reported
in percentages measuring growth, as is there's
no way to accurately compare them. For one
thing, each row of our wages data is the percentage
by which wages whatever is in that quarter
had the current rate continued for a full
12 months. So not only do those values not
correspond to the absolute CPI price data,
they're not even technically true of their
own timeframe. So when we're told that the
rate for the first quarter of 2002 was 3.5%.
That means that if wages continued to rise
at the current first quarter rate, for a full
12 months, the annual average growth would
have been 3.5%, but not 14%, which means the
numbers we're going to work with will have
to be adjusted. That's because the actual
growth during say the three months of 2002,
quarter one wasn't 3.5%, but only a quarter
of that, or 0.875%. If I don't make this adjustment,
but continue to map quarterly growth numbers
to quarterly CPI prices that are calculated
output would lead us to think that wages are
growing so fast, that they become detached
from reality. Now, I should warn you that
solving this compatibility problem will require
some fake math, I'm going to divide each quarterly
growth rate by four or in other words, I'll
pretend that the real changes to wages during
those three months were exactly one quarter
of the reported year over year rate. I'm sure
that's almost certainly not true. And it's
a gross simplification. However, for the big
historical picture I'm trying to draw here,
it's probably close enough. Now that will
still leave us with a number that's a percentage,
but the corresponding CPI number we're comparing
it to is again a point figure. To solve this
problem. I'll apply one more piece of fakery.
To convert those percentages to match the
CPI values, I'm going to create a function,
I'll feed the function the starting 2002 first
quarter CPI value of 170 7.1. That'll be my
baseline. I'll give that variable the name
new num. For each iteration, the function
will make through the rows of my wages data
series, I'll divide the current wage value
x by 400. Where'd I get that number 100 simply
converts the percentage to 3.5, etc, to a
decimal 0.035. And the four will reduce the
annual or 12 month rate to a quarterly rate
covering three months to convert that to a
usable number a multiply it by the current
value of new num, and then add new num to
the product. That should give us an approximation
of the original CPI value adjusted by the
related wage growth percentage. But of course,
this won't be a number that has any direct
equivalent in the real world. Instead, it
is, as I said, an arbitrary approximation
of what that number might have been. But again,
I think it'll be close enough for our purposes.
Take a moment to read through the function.
Global new num declares a variable as global.
This makes it possible for me to replace the
original value of new num with the functions
output, so the percentage in the next row
will be adjusted by the updated value. Note
also how any strings will be ignored. And
finally, Note how the updated data series
will populate the new wages data variable.
Let's check that new data looks great. Our
next task will be to merge our two data frames
and then plot their data. Don't go away. What's
left, we need to merge our two data series
so Python can compare them. But since we've
already done all the cleaning up and manipulation,
this will go smoothly. I'll create a new data
frame called merge data and feed it with the
URL Put up this PD merge function, I simply
supply the names of my two data frames and
specify that the date column should be the
index. That wasn't hard. Let's take a look.
Our data is all there, we can visually scan
through the CPI and wages columns and look
for any unusual relationships. But that defeats
the point. Python data analytics is all about
letting our code do that for us. Let's plot
the thing. Here, we'll tell plot to take our
merge data frame merge data and create a bar
chart. Because there's an awful lot of data
here, I'll extend the size of the chart with
a manual fixed size value, I set the x axis
to use values in the date column. And again,
because there are so many of them, I'll rotate
the labels by 45 degrees to make them more
readable. Finally, I'll set the labels for
the x and y axes. This is what comes out the
other end, because of the crowding, it's not
especially easy to read. But you can see that
the orange wages bars are for the most part
higher than the blue CPI bars. That means
that wages are experiencing a higher growth
rate than the CPI, we'll have a stab at analyzing
some of this a bit later, is there an easier
way to display all this data, you bet there
is I can change the value of kind from bar
to line, and things will instantly improve.
Here's how the new code will work as a line
plot and with the grid.
Python, along with its associated libraries,
gives us the ability to use a much wider variety
of plotting tools than just bar and line graphs.
We're going to explore just two of them here,
scatter plots, and histograms. We'll also
talk a bit about how regression lines work,
and what kinds of insights they can show us.
We'll begin with scatter plots. This code
is from the property rights and economic development
chapter on my Teach Yourself data analytics
website, you can catch up on the background
over there. But the code you're looking at
comes from two data sources, the World Bank's
measure of per capita gross domestic product
by country and the index of economic freedom
data from the heritage.org site, I merged
data from the two data frames into this one
called merge data, I'll create a simple scatterplot.
With this one line command, we can clearly
see a pattern, the higher the per capita gross
domestic product, meaning the more economic
activity a country generates, the further
to the right on the x axis, a country's dot
is likely to fall. And the further to the
right, the higher is the economic freedom
score. Of course, there are anomalies in our
data. There are countries whose position appears
way out of range of all the others, it'd be
nice if we could somehow see which countries
those are, and would also be nice if we could
quantify the precise statistical relationship
between our two values, rather than having
to visually guess. We'll begin by visualizing
those anomalies in our data. To make this
happen. all important another couple of libraries
that are part of the plotly family of tools,
you may need to manually install them on your
host using pip install plotly. Before those
will work. From there, we can run p x scatter,
and point it to our merged data data frame
associating the score column with the x axis
and value with the y axis. So we'll be able
to hover over a dot and see the data it represents.
We'll add the hover data argument and tell
it to include country and score data. This
time when you run the code, you get the same
nice plot. But if you hover your mouse over
any dot, you'll also see its data values.
In this example, you can see that the tiny
but rich country of Luxembourg has an economic
freedom score of 75.9 and a per capita GDP
of more than $121,000. You can similarly pick
out other countries at either end of the chart,
we can learn more about the statistical relationship
between our values by adding a regression
line, a measure of the data is R squared value.
We already saw how our plot showed a visible
trend up and to the right. But we also saw
there were outliers. Can we be confident that
the outliers are the exceptions, and that
the overall relationship between our two data
sources is sound. There's only so much we
can assume based on visually viewing the graph
at some point, we'll need hard numbers to
describe what we're looking at. A simple linear
regression analysis can give us a measure
of the strength of the relationship between
a dependent variable and the data model. r
squared is a number between zero and 100%.
Where 100% would indicate a perfect fit. Of
course, in the real world, a 100% fit is next
to impossible. You'll judge The accuracy of
your model or assumption within the context
of the data you're working with, how can you
add a regression line to a panda's chart?
There are, as always, many ways to go about
it, I like simple and the O LS trend line
approach is about as simple as it gets, just
add a trendline argument to the code we've
already been using. That's it. Oh LS By the
way, stands for ordinary least squares, which
is a, which is a type of linear regression.
And here's how it looked with our regression
line. When I hover over the line, I'm showing
an R squared value of 0.550451. Or in other
words around 35%. For our purposes, I consider
that a pretty strong correlation. a histogram
is a plotting tool that breaks your data down
into bins. A bin is actually an approximation
of a statistically appropriate interval between
sets of your data bins attempt to guess at
the probability density function
PDF, that will best represent the values you're
actually using. But they may not display exactly
the way you think, especially when you use
a default value. I'll illustrate how this
works or actually how it doesn't work. Using
data from the do birthdays make elite athletes
chapter on the website. As you can see over
there, I'd scraped the semi official NHL API
for the birth dates of around 1100 current
NHL players. My goal was to visualize the
distribution of their birth dates across all
12 months to see if their births were concentrated
within a specific yearly season. When I display
the data using a histogram, we didn't see
the pattern we'd expected. In fact, the pattern
wasn't truly representative of the real world.
That's because histograms are great for showing
frequency distributions by grouping data points
together into bins. This can help us quickly
visualize the state of a very large data set
where granular precision will get in the way,
but it can be misleading for use cases like
ours. Since we were looking for a literal
mapping of events to calendar dates. Even
setting the bin amount to 12. to match the
number of months won't help, because a histogram
won't necessarily stick to those exact borders.
What we really need here is a plain old bar
graph that incorporates our value counts numbers,
I'll pipe the results of value counts to a
data frame called df one, and then plot that
as a simple bar graph. In the next module,
we're going to talk about understanding our
data visualizations, and integrating what
we see in our Jupyter Notebooks with stuff
that happens out there. In the real world.
Stay tuned. We're supposed to be doing data
analytics here, such as staring at pretty
graphs probably isn't the whole point. The
CPI and wages data sets we plotted in the
previous chapter, for instance, showed us
a clear general correlation. But there were
some visually recognizable anomalies. Unless
we can connect those anomalies with historical
events, and explain them in a historical context,
we won't be getting the full value from our
data. But even before going there, we should
confirm that our plots actually make sense
in the context of their data sources. Working
with our BLS examples, let's look at graphs
to compare CPI and wages data from both before
and after our manipulation. That way, we can
be sure that our math and particularly our
fake math didn't skew things too badly. Here's
what our CPI data look like when plotted using
the raw data. It's certainly a busy graph,
but you can clearly see the gentle upward
slope punctuated by a handful of sudden jumps.
Next, we'll see that same data after removing
three out of every four months data points,
the same ups and downs are still visible.
Given our overall goals. I'd categorize our
transformation as a success. Now, how about
the wages data here, because we move from
percentages to currency, the transformation
was more intrusive, and the risks of misrepresentation
were greater. We'll also need to take into
account the way a percentage will display
differently from an absolute value. Here's
the original data. Note how there's no consistent
curve, either upwards or downwards. That's
because we're measuring the rate of growth
as it took place within each individual quarter,
not the growth itself. Now compare that with
this line graph of that wage data now converted
to currency based values. The gentle curve,
you see makes some sense, it's about real
growth after all, not growth rates, but it's
also possible to recognize a few spots where
the curve steepens and others where it smooths
out a bit more. Why are the slopes so smooth
in comparison with the percentage based data?
Look at the y axis labels. The index graph
is measured in points between 180 and 280.
While the percentage graph goes from zero
to 3.5. It's the scale that's different. All
in all, I believe we're safe concluding that
what we produced is a good match with our
source data. establishing some kind of historical
context for your data will require looking
for anomalies and associating them with known
historical events. That's something I do at
length in the wages and CPI Reality Check
chapter on the website. If you're interested,
I'm sure you'll work through that material
on your own. But I think you've seen enough
here to get a picture of how plotting the
right visualization can be helpful.
But that brings us to the end of this particular
course, as I've mentioned, a number of times
already, the full curriculum is available
on my the data project dotnet site, and you're
more than welcome to join all the cool kids
over there and be in touch if you've got something
to add to the conversation. The main thing
is to realize that the end of this course
isn't anywhere near the end of your data analytics
education. watching me calmly execute nice,
clean code samples isn't really learning.
Unless you're a very special breed of genius,
you won't begin to understand how all this
really works. Until you dive in and work things
through yourself. I say worth things through.
But what I really mean is not worth things
through because it's mistakes and frustration
that are the best teachers. Don't imagine
that my Python code just came to exist on
a quiet afternoon. While I was sipping nice
hot coffee. First of all, I don't drink coffee.
But more to the point, there was nothing quiet
about it. There were humiliating failures,
reformulations start overs and countless trips
to stack overflow before things began to take
shape. But the more problems I faced and overcame,
the deeper the process sank into my mind,
and the better I got at it. And so will you
just be prepared for tough times ahead. Before
you all run off and get on with your day,
let's spend a moment or two reviewing everything
we saw here. We spoke about the many ways
you can work with Jupyter notebooks, including
online platforms like Google's Collaboratory,
and locally hosting either Jupiter lab or
plastic notebooks within introduced ourselves
to the Jupiter environment, learning about
cells kernels and the operating environment.
We saw how we can find data through public
API's and how to integrate API credentials
into our Python environment. Python libraries
and modules were our next focus, including
how to import appropriate libraries to allow
us to effectively clean and manipulate our
data. And finally, turning to some actual
data analytics. We learned some basics of
plotting, including working with scatter plots,
regression lines and histograms. And we closed
out the chorus with a quick discussion of
how to use our data visualizations to integrate
our insights with the real world. I hope this
has been helpful for you and I invite you
to check out some of my other content on my
main website, bootstrap dash it.com. Take
care